[Music]
in addition to his membership in the
scientology cult tom cruise can be
accused of many things
but on set he's always very friendly and
professional to its fellow employees
however there has now been a scandal on
the set of mission impossible 7.
production has recently started again
after the significant increase of
difficulties on set due to the pandemic
crews through allowed a lengthy tantrum
right after two employees had a
conversation without sticking to the
required minimum distance on the london
set he did some frank talking that we
leave out for the sake of advertiser
friendly content
but this much we can't say he went so
far as to threaten
several times to immediately fire those
affected the next time they break social
distancing rules
he claimed that they could not afford to
take another break in filming since
there are thousands of jobs depending on
hollywood production
his upset is totally understandable
because in addition to the already tense
situation in the entire industry part 8
of mission impossible is going to begin
production
immediately after the ongoing production
of part 7.
further a novelty with cruz namely a
movie that takes place
in space is in the works the space
travel which is planned for october 2021
cannot be postponed due to the tight
schedule
another discontinuation of the filming
activities could thus quite possibly
mean an organizational disaster
according to an insider cruz has been
paying close attention to the compliance
with the regulations since the
resumption of filming and apparently he
has even been doing his
own safety inspection tours anyhow a
large majority of the online community
supports tom cruise and his clear
statement
the release of mission impossible 7 is
expected to be on november 18th
2021 after we saw first concept art for
the new game of thrones prequel house of
the dragon last week
deadline now reports about three
newcomers olivia cook
matt smith and emma darcy there's also
paddy considine who was cast as king
viserys targaryen back in october
olivia cook is going to play the role of
alison hightower the daughter of auto
high tower whereas emma darcy is
familiarizing herself with the role of
princess rhaenyra targaryen
the oldest child of king viserys actor
matt smith also plays a family member
namely the younger brother of the king
and heir to the throne daemon targaryen
the plot takes place about 300 years
before the main series
and it'll explore the history of the
house targaryen the series is directly
based on george rr martin's book fire
and blood and it is directed by miguel
sapochnick
and the company of showrunner ryan j
condle with a release planned for
2022 the annual list of 25 films that
are going to be included in the national
film registry was released on monday the
whole purpose behind this is the
acknowledgement of national cultural
assets from the film world
the decision is made by the us library
of congress
for musicals through to action movies
any movie can be part of it
hence also the blues brothers from 1980
or the dark knight from 2008 a personal
highlight is none other than
shrek the first movie of course from now
on our reckless hero is among the
greatest film of the last decades
well deserved do we think
for a long time it wasn't clear whether
zack snyder's justice league would get a
cinema release
at all with the controversial warner
plans of publishing all the big movies
of 2021 simultaneously on hbo max and on
the big screen
there shouldn't really be any further
drawbacks due to schneider being a big
fan of cinema releases himself
he consequently insists justice league
to be released in theaters as well
but so far without any official
statement from warner brothers
he did have to wait long enough after
all the director had to leave his
project at an early stage because of
family reasons which made him hand over
the post-production to joss whedon with
the rather moderate success
there's also news in regards to age
restriction because according to
snyder's own comment
an our rating is to be expected on the
one hand
there are many efforts on the other hand
explicit violence is very often shown
the us release of zeck snyder's justice
league is said to be in march 2021
a potential cinema release date has yet
to be announced
at the present time things are not going
well for the shooting for the second
season of
the witcher recently the production had
to be halted due to staff members who
had tested positive
now it's the main actor himself who has
to put a stop to the recordings as
deadline reports
the 37 year old actor suffered a not
inconsiderable leg injury on a kind of
obstacle course the result a break from
filming for a witcher for now at least
even so the production crew continues
filming and tries to shoot as many
scenes as possible without the main
character let's hope that kevill
and the witcher team will recover well
from this setback there's good news
nonetheless the marketing team asked on
twitter whether fans would rather see
cuts from season 1 or a surprise
the witcher fans clearly decided in
favor of the surprise
and that came promptly because shortly
afterwards new images for the new season
were published so the next question was
whether the fans would rather see a
script page or another surprise
here too the fans opted for the latter
it is to be expected that even more
content will be released in the upcoming
days
we are definitely excited
[Music]
you